I'm like really gonna be a happy person
so I just try to just accept the things
that are go along with it and some of it
sucks but you know everyone has things
in life that suck you know and so I just
take it to the chin I guess take it to
the chin or to the comments after a fan
wrote this Instagram comment to Justin
claiming he only married Haley to get
back at SG aka Selena Gomez Justin
totally clapped back posting this
lengthy response which says in part
quote I absolutely loved and loved
Selena she will always hold a place in
my heart but I am head over heels in
love with my wife and she is absolutely
the best thing that has ever happened to
me period he's just really sweet he's a
good kid it's a good heart and I love
him Justin also called the user immature
and said if you don't like that he
married Haley you're not a real fan
this all comes after Justin posted
another long message on Instagram
addressing his mental health quote I am
now very focused on repairing some of
the deep-rooted issues that I have so
that I don't fall apart so that I can
sustain my marriage and be the father I
want to be yeah he said father but he
and Haley aren't expecting just yet
a source tells ET Justin and Haley have
talked about kids and it's a priority to
them adding their friends wouldn't be
surprised if that happened soon we have
a family wife some kids indoor
basketball court
and indoor pool I want to build it and
stuff I want to find the right place
earlier this month Halley and Justin did
find the right place
purchasing a new home in Beverly Hills
I've gotten to a place where I have like
a core group and people who are really
supporting me and encouraging me and
don't worry if you're hoping for new
music from the Biebs he did say he'll
have an album out ASAP quote my swag is
undeniable and my drive is indescribable
[Music]